[Music]
foreign
welcome to Tech news briefing for Friday
April 28th I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
Benjamin Franklin once wrote that
nothing is certain except death and
taxes but nowadays there's another issue
to sort out your digital footprint the
photos social media accounts and other
digital assets you create during your
life our family and Tech columnist Julie
jargon joins us later in the show to
talk about how to pass on access to your
online accounts and it's been a busy
week for Tech earnings we'll find out
what the first quarter results that are
out so far tell us about the health of
the tech sector
foreign
reported a surge in growth rebounding
from a post-pandemic slump in sales the
Commerce giant said first quarter sales
Rose nine percent compared with the same
period a year earlier quarterly profit
also climbed coming in almost 50 percent
higher than analysts expected Amazon
like other Tech firms has been cutting
costs and shedding workers the company
said it would finish laying off roughly
9 000 corporate employees by the end of
this month it's already cut about 18 000
workers in an earlier round of layoffs
Amazon is just the latest in a series of
big tech companies that have posted
earnings this week with me to discuss
the picture these results are painting
is our heard on the street Tech
columnist Dan Gallagher Dan meta
Microsoft Google parent alphabet they
all released their earnings earlier this
week what is all of this telling us
about the health of the tech sector well
it's telling us a couple things you know
the tech sector is very much affected by
the global economy me which is in a
pretty slow phase so on the surface
these are pretty slow growth results for
the most part these were not the kind of
double-digit big gains that we are
typically seeing with these companies
however another Dynamic going into this
particular earnings season was that Wall
Street really expected bad numbers so
the dynamic for those three is that they
were able to exceed these rather lowball
expectations so as a result they
actually looked pretty good so the
stocks all went up following meta's
earnings in particular seemed Rosy
compared against some analyst
expectations operating profit was up
sales were up is this a sign that Mark
Zuckerberg's cuts his year of efficiency
as he put it is paying off for the
company it's definitely a sign of that
and they're still not even done you know
what they cautioned is that well we saw
in the numbers kind of reflects only
about half of those reductions so far
because they announced a big cut late
last year and then they announced one in
March and so what we were seeing in the
actual numbers was just selecting last
year's cuts what about digital
advertising which has been a sore spot
for meta and others advertising is also
proving to be a little bit better than
people expected for both Google and for
Facebook meta Platforms in fact the
advertising revenue is growing again for
meta and it wasn't for a few quarters
and that was a bit of good news for them
and Google search ad business held up
even though YouTube hasn't let's talk a
little bit about Cloud business I mean
for companies like Amazon Google
Microsoft that's a big chunk of their
earnings so how have those units been
faring as the broader economy deals with
kind of shrinking market conditions that
is where I think they benefited from the
lowball expectations because yes growth
in all those Cloud businesses is slowing
and it showed even at Microsoft which
had what Wall Street considered a really
good report that way have their slowest
Cloud growth on record but it was a
little bit better than people expected
it's showing that that's a business that
is pretty resilient because if you're a
big company and you've adopted a lot of
cloud technology and service contracts
you don't just like cut those off
because the economy slumps it's kind of
part of your ongoing thing now but the
other side of it is that you know
companies that are contemplating shifts
to the cloud or increasing their spend
in this kind of environment they're
doing that at a much slower Pace more
Tech results are coming out next week so
what will you be watching for with them
well the big one to come next week is
obviously apple and that's that's a
pretty different business than the ones
we've been talking about because that is
still mostly a hardware business iPhones
iPads Mac computers that's probably not
going to be another big growth story
obviously in fact the signs are that the
current iPhone cycle is kind of a is
kind of a weak one and they're very much
a company now that has like a big year
of growth about every two or three years
and then between that is kind of flat
because now people hold on to their
devices for longer periods you know for
Apple you also watch like services and
stuff that's attached to that Hardware
but we're also going to see next week
reports coming from companies like uber
and doordash some of these like gig
economy companies that might be
reflective of how consumers are spending
on technology type Services all right
that's wsj's hurt on the street Tech
columnist Dan Gallagher Dan thanks for
joining us
we're all creating digital Footprints
everything from our photos emails
Banking and other accounts so what
happens to that information once we die
it may sound morbid to think about but
it's becoming increasingly important for
loved ones to know how to gain access to
this data so they can close bank
accounts Safeguard important documents
and find Family Photos Julie jargon our
family and Tech columnist joins us now
to talk through the best ways to do this
so Julie you actually spoke to some
people who've experienced what happens
when loved ones don't have a plan for
their digital Footprints can you tell us
about their experience yeah I spoke with
a woman who lost her longtime partner in
February and the two of them were Avid
photographers and they had thousands and
thousands of photos saved in his iCloud
account she had access to his passwords
and she had them saved but apparently at
one point you know he'd had dementia and
he had gone online and done some
tinkering and he apparently changed his
Apple ID password without telling her so
after he passed away she started to see
emails to him saying that his iCloud
account payments for storage was overdue
and his credit cards had been shut off
after he died and she was worried about
losing access to his iCloud account and
all those photos that they had saved she
turned to someone in her retirement
community for help turns out that his
iPad was still signed into his Apple ID
and so that made it a trusted device and
she was able to go into the iPad's
settings and change his Apple ID
password and restore the payment system
under her credit card and regain access
to all the photos I mean that sounds
really lucky because of course you know
even to our email addresses to our
social media accounts we can have some
really personal information that we once
shared with our loved ones when we're
gone so let's get into how we should
deal with this first you know we have so
many passwords for so many accounts
what's the best way to ensure that those
get passed on to the people we want them
to you know a lot of people write down
on paper their passwords to accounts but
oftentimes you're prompted to change a
password for security reasons or you
forget your password and you reset it so
a lot of people will suggest that you
have a password manager which will keep
track of your passwords automatically
and if you do have a password manager
it's really easy to designate a contact
who can be granted access to your
password manager after you die or if you
become injured and incapacitated okay so
it's almost like you're talking about
having an error to your passwords could
you also have an heir to your online
accounts like the way we have inheritors
of our our homes or other property you
can do that with specific online
accounts bank accounts and that kind of
thing but if you have a password manager
where everything's in one place those
people can then have access to all of
your accounts and it could be you know
accounts that you might not think are
that important maybe your your Netflix
account or some online magazine in
subscriptions but things that might just
need to be dealt with and closed out so
you don't keep getting charged or the
estate of the person who passed away
doesn't keep getting charged after they
die God there are just so many accounts
that we build up over our lives what
about ones that we use maybe every day
like an Apple account or a Google
account that might be connected to our
emails for example exactly both Apple
and Google have ways to name Legacy
contacts in the case of Apple it's
really easy to just set it up from the
settings in your iPhone or your iPad or
your Mac and you can name someone that
you trust and then what it does is it
provides a pass key a long alphanumeric
access key and you have to share that
with your legacy contact that way when
you pass away that person can reach out
to Apple provide proof that the person
died by showing their death certificate
and providing that long access key and
then they can get in and have access to
photos messages notes files device
backups what about people's social media
accounts there are ways to memorialize
Facebook and Instagram
profiles Facebook however is currently
the only big social media platform that
allows Legacy contacts to be named
their advice that listeners should take
away if they want to make a plan for
their digital footprint once they've
passed yeah it's also really important
to have a talk with your family members
or loved ones about your digital assets
if you just hand them a list of
passwords or grant them access to all of
these accounts they may not know what
you want to have done with it so you
might want to tell them whether you want
your social media accounts to be
memorialized or whether you want certain
things to be deleted whether you want
them to be able to download your data
it's probably a good idea to just really
make your wishes very clear all right
that's some advice from our family and
Tech columnist Julie jargon Julie thanks
for joining us and that's it for this
week's Tech news briefing tnb's producer
is Julie Chang we had production
assistants from just Jupiter and Zoe
Culkin our supervising producer is
Melanie Roy and our executive producer
is Chris sinsley I'm your host Zoe
Thomas thanks for listening and have a
great weekend
foreign
[Music]